ouais ouais non plusieurs locataires de
la rue jean brillon dans
l'arrondissement lasalle à montréal se
plaint d'être infectés par des punaises
de lit et autres vermines
c'est le cas de marc amoudry abri et de
sa famille ça sur la chambre de ma fille
et sa ppsr leçon aux que d'abandonner
lâchant à cause des punaises et ça fait
trois fois comme ça que j'ai un matelas
combien de temps il dit paient 960 $ par
mois pour son catherine me si vous
voulez des brefs et les voilà la mesure
qui n'a pas voulu être identifié à la
caméra doit cohabiter avec des souris
qui s'infiltrent depuis des années par
les pets elektriks horizontaux jouera
parce qu'ils sont nombreuses le matelas
le taux sommier est lui aussi cité tout
neuf
après avoir formulé plusieurs plaintes
il convenu d'une entente à l'amiable
avec son gestionnaire d'immeubles
theodorus wild et s'attend à des
résultats ici assuré il faut les traiter
poursuite gok il faut le traiter tout de
suite la compagnie en charge de la
gestion de ces immeubles dit avoir
investi 70 mille dollars en prêts
d'exterminateurs au cours des cinq
dernières années
elle déplore que certains locataires
tarde trop avant d'informer leurs
gestionnaires ceux qui sont contrôle de
l'eau lors de leur logement
donc s'ils veulent leur logement soit
salut etc les coquerelles ou souris ne
viennent pas dans leur logement il faut
qu'ils collaborent avec l'exterminateur
pourtant selon la loi la responsabilité
incombe en majeure partie aux locateurs
précise cet avocat leurs responsabilités
principales
toujours pour la préparation incluant
pour les verbes les aime c'est grave
hier au locateur à la ville de montréal
on ne veut pas s'avancer sur un nombre
précis de logements insalubres
toutefois on a un qi le nombre
d'inspections et le nombre d'amendés est
resté plutôt stable ici gabriel pro ado
canada montréal